good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight happy Friday according to a news
report that dropped last night Michael
Cohen that is of course Donald Trump's
former personal attorney is prepared to
testify in the Muller probe that the
president knew about a June 2016 meeting
in New York City between his son Don jr.
and a Russian lawyer who had claimed she
had dirt on the Hillary Clinton campaign
that's the claim so for the sake of
argument let's assume that all of it is
literally true what does it mean exactly
and why should we care if you've been
watching television over the past 24
hours you already know the answers to
the those questions what this means is
the end of the Trump presidency if not
of the United States itself we should
care because nothing in human history
since the harnessing of fire and the
invention of the wheel isn't as
inherently momentous as this Don juniors
brief meeting two years ago with an
unknown Russian lawyer called Natalya
vessel Metz kaya
who knew about this meeting and when did
they know about it and what were they
wearing when they met it is on questions
like these at the fates of nations hang
here's a selection of both the huffing
and the puffing that puts Donald Trump
in a conspiratorial mode on this on this
issue before the fact that evidence on
its face if it was supported would be an
impeachable offense it shows that he had
he had prior knowledge that the Russians
were seeking to do this and he didn't
stop the meeting he was giving a green
light for the Russians to interfere
until now we have not had a smoking gun
that placed Donald Trump's senior the
President himself in the center of the
conspiracy this is potentially huge this
is potentially something that can prove
the president colluded and that isn't
that is an impeachable offense so
there's criminal liability here for the
president on the horizon well so there
you have it internationally recognized
genius max boot thinks this is a big
deal is it well if the president lied
about it or anything else under oath yes
it is that would be a big deal
perjury is always a big deal but don't
tell Bill Clinton's defenders that
otherwise though it's hard to see the
point of all of this hysteria what
exactly with the crime here be it's not
illegal to talk to foreigners nobody is
claiming that any information changed
hands though even if it did so what is
principled Lefty Glenn Greenwald wrote
this afternoon quote if getting dirt
about your opponent from foreign
officials is immoral or treasonous why
was it okay for DNC representatives to
be trolling around Ukraine working with
foreign officials to get dirt on
Manafort and Trump because Ukraine
favored Hillary huh good question
keep in mind too that the Democratic
National Committee and the Clinton
campaign both paid a foreign national
his name is Christopher steel together
damaging information on Donald Trump
from other foreign nationals including
and especially from Russians and unlike
the Trump campaign the Democrats
actually succeeded they produced an
entire dossier based on misinformation
from Russian sources that dossier
changed the course of American history
the Obama administration used it to spy
on its political opponents and to begin
a series of investigations that have
from the very first day overshadowed it
in some cases neutered the Trump
administration pretty effective just in
case you're looking for actual examples
of foreign collusion now Democrats are
claiming just the opposite of course
accusing their opponents of doing pretty
much exactly what they themselves did at
first that may look like hypocrisy and
it is but it's more than that it's a
political tactic you scream as loud as
you can
in the hope that your opponents will be
intimidated into accepting your
essentially fraudulent premise it often
works and that's exactly why they do it
but it only works when the rest of us
play along with it so let's stop playing
along with it